what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich russell's
trying to get our lunch money right i'm
here paulina is here
block five's the sponsor go to block
five dot com slash pomp go get a block
fight account
let's get this cracking you can earn up
to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account go to
blockfight.com
pomp let's go we got eight minutes and
we're gonna motor through this
during thursday's game stop hearing
citadel securities ken griffin defended
a controversial method
brokerages used to make money called
payment for order flow and said his firm
would adapt
if new regulations prohibited the
practice
they should call this screw the little
guy that's what it should be called not
payment for order flow it's called screw
the little guy
it's where they front run you but he
said we simply play by the rules of the
road
payment for order flow had been
expressly approved by the sec
it is a customary practice within the
industry if they choose to change the
rules of the road we need to drive on
the left side versus the right side
that's fine with us aren't they like
bankrupt no
no they make a lot of money by the way
he's right he is playing by the rules
he's doing exactly what he's allowed to
do
and he should do it it's his
responsibility to exploit the rules
but it's still screw the little guy and
it's still front-running little guys
so call it what it is and if you want to
change the rules change the rules i'm
not even advocating for changing the
rules i'm just advocating people to opt
the hell out of this stupid casino game
and go play elsewhere in the digital
markets where there's
not all this nonsense going on don't
play a rigged game
play one that is suited for you
before congress on thursday reddit ceo
steve huffman defended the role of his
platform played
defended the role that his platform
reddit played in the january surge of
gamestop shares which raised a host of
questions
about market regulation huffman
testified
that reddit's moderation mechanism makes
it particularly good
at weeding out bad information he also
said that financial advice from reddit
users
may actually be more reliable than
advice from traditional media
because it is vetted by the community
decentralizations
versus centralized faxing and also if
you go in and you look sure there's
memes there's gifts there's
uh all these jokes but there's good
information
so let's roll redditors to the moon
bitcoin to the moon redditors to the
moon wall street bets to the moon let's
go the dow jones
rised raised rose rose 150 points after
janet yellen called for more stimulus
because 1.9 trillion was not enough
yellen is calling for more
yeah those are the monetary stimulus
bombs going off
3 trillion last year then they added
another 900 billion
now they're saying there's another 1.9
trillion then they're now
saying last night they started a rumor
of three more trillion
they are talking about 4.9 trillion
dollars coming down the pipe there was
less than three and a half trillion in
the fed's
uh balance sheet in august of 2019 they
said
and they started firing off the bombs
we're now at 7.5 trillion dollars on the
fed's balance sheet
it's the highest of all time they've
never had more money sitting in their
uh on that balance sheet and now they're
talking about another four
trillion dollars 4.9 trillion dollars or
these people absolutely lost their
damn minds they literally are going to
take the dollar and they're just going
to crumble it up and they're gonna
shoot it in the trash copy why because
they are literally devaluing it into
trash
they're just making the dollar into
trash if you're holding the dollar
you're gonna lose money if you invest
your money you'll be better off
the uk supreme court upheld a ruling
that uber's drivers should be classified
as workers rather than independent
contractors this is a big deal guys
uber insists its drivers are
self-employed and that it acts as more
of an agency which connects them with
passengers through the app
the ruling potentially jeopardizes
uber's business model in the uk
and has major implications for the
country's gig
economy wow the uk is always two steps
behind the us
the u.s already had this battle the uk
is like oh let us get into the battle
by the way the uk also sometimes for
those of you that live in the uk they'll
be doing all kinds of crazy stuff over
there that don't make no sense ain't
none of that flying
in the free market capitalistic society
in the united states
all right oh by the way the uk probably
handled a lot of stuff better than the
us too so you know it's a
double edge okay you're gonna like this
one nasa
landed perseverance rover on the mars
surface carrying the first helicopter
for another planet
also the only thing better than this
scientific uh
accomplishment is how big this cup is
bigger than my head and your head
combined
wow it's 64 ounces if you're curious on
amazon
he loves it loves it all right
so listen okay hold on hold on we went
to mars i saw this meme that said
that said uh mars is the only planet
solely occupied by robots
it's true aliens are there there's
aliens listen why do you like this big
cup
because this is my cup there are many
like it but this one is mine you can't
have it don't touch it
and get your germs on this we went to
mars ain't nobody want
to kids show bleep that
ain't nobody want to talk about the fact
that we got to mars
which means that next time they're going
to be sending humans
and when the humans get there they're
going to walk out there and they'll be
like hello
that is a large cup cheers for the
weekend
there's water in here i promise she
didn't put this on there
but bitcoin hit another all-time high 54
000 54 000 who cares about the us dollar
price ain't nobody care about the us
price
other than it proves that the haters
were wrong
they're haters they're losers they're
bears as i told you over and over and
over and over again
on this show don't be a pessimist
pessimism is for losers if you're a
short seller you're a loser
stop being a pessimist come join the
optimist we got big cups we got
big bags and we got a high bitcoin price
bitcoin to the moon
humans are sending machines to mars and
i'm signing off after we do this next
segment
can you do your dance again no okay so
um it's ask lunch money time
ask l m hashtag ask ellen he was very
dehydrated so i bought him this big cup
and
he's very hydrated okay hashtag ask
ellen in the comments bobby ryan what
you know about
overalls well bobby if you saw i was
wearing them yesterday i've been wearing
them today maybe i wear them tomorrow i
know a lot about overalls i've been
wearing overalls for longer than this
cup's been in this apartment
bobby ask better questions okay
but by the way overalls are cool i'm a
big overall fan go ahead yeah
oh my god oh my gosh well there's books
in the comments
i got time i got i got things to do
you're writing a book day six of
commenting
uh he said the rock is definitely the
presidential candidate of the people it
would be nice to have someone in the
oval office that can
bench two plates i don't know okay moist
okay getting that 225
rolling i don't know what that means
that means 225 pounds you put 245s on
either side 225 no it's 45's and not
like 100's
try because literally if you've ever
been to a gym you know two plates what
it means the fact of the day about me is
i recently re-downloaded twitter oh i
read it as tinder after having deleted
it as palm suggested a few episodes ago
it makes for a nice resource
for crypto news by following the right
accounts i don't necessarily love using
it though because i'd rather not give my
service to a company that heavily
sensors material
in one direction moist listen i thought
he said tinder and i was like i don't
understand why you would get twitter
twitter
twitter moist i appreciate it i still
need more information my next question
moist is
if you had to go to the grocery store
and only eat one cereal
for a year what are you picking do not
screw this up moist if you screw this up
it is a deal breaker
we'll literally cut off the whole
competition now one cereal for a year
what is the one cereal that you would
choose most bizarre questions your
head's bizarre
you know what else is bizarre as they're
printing so much money that the world's
gonna end
see ya bang bang hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of lunch money as much as
we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest-bearing account go do your own
research
there's risk associated but 8.6 is
pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends